Judy Garland has to be one of the
greatest singers of all time right in
your opinion if not the greatest yeah do
you think you're the greatest singer of
all time you could make a yeah you could
make a good argument don't don't be
humble you you could make a good
argument I have to be humble no I have a
very good voice Judy has a great great
voice she's spectacular did you see her
as tragic the way I see her I mean I
felt her life was so sad I did I did I
did did I did and she was kind and
truthful supportive and she still
grasped my hand when we were singing
together she was holding on to me and I
saw she needed support I mean we became
close friends what did you make of her
life in other words she became so at a
very young age really she was in her 40s
I mean she became addicted to Pills and
everything the business kind of killed
her she became because she was a child
actress and she was fed all those pills
to keep her up to put her to sleep
da when and I think you have to have
that Gene also genetically that makes
you want to drink you know what I mean
when she met you do you think she was
threatened by you at all like you were
this young girl with this fantastic
voice and now here comes you know
Barbara sitting on a stool right next to
Judy you know in other words she
was she was real you know she made a
joke out of it she says Barbara I hate
you you know what I'm saying in other
words one uses what you think PE we have
we have different thoughts about people
it's not one thing we're more complex
than that you know I was thrilled to be
singing with her um intimidated at all I
thought she sang so brilliantly that
show yeah much better than me you know
she she came from a background that was
so different than mine but we still felt
each other's pain when you were on TV
and she's singing get happy you're doing
Happy Days Are Here Again do you know in
that
moment I am now creating one of the
classic alltime greatest moments in
television history do you are you aware
of it do you don't think I was I I maybe
a little but I mean Marty said you know
that was just classic I mean and I mean
I thought what a great idea the two of
us singing together but you know it's
just
great